[Musica]
perché c'è uno schifosissimo ragno che
si che fa schifo bella a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo gioco di ragni con
gli occhi nel corpo della mera prenderò
un po di funghi altro a casa questa è la
partenza di questo gioco fantastico non
vedevo l'ora x meno male che è così che
hanno comprato prendiamo i funghetti
aries
mica vogliamo dei ragni grossi con gli
occhi quando aveva la prendiamo
funghetti e basta non sia un gioco
interessante perché comunque la partenza
è buona voglio dire mi sembra mi sembra
che stiamo parlando la stessa lingua e
proprio il classico gioco che comprerei
nella mia vita c'è una staccionata
bello c'è una b e finché non ci sono
ragnetti è tutto a posto che per te
entro di qua che bello io volevo solo a
non si entra posso sbirciare dentro una
sedia open la porta è chiusa magari la
chiave nascosta da qualche parte ok
eccola qua subito non vedo neanche la
porta capuana che è successo
che io sarei partito la quadro
riprendere i funghetti va bene quindi mi
vuoi dire che questa non è amsterdam
fratello comunque il discorso è che
continua entrare lì e mi ammazzeranno
sempre magari non entrò me va da
un'altra parte non credo che forse tra
l'al della dentro e promuovendo da
vedere ma che chiama sbarcato l'anno
spara fano di fuggire
so che dovevo era era un fucile ma dai
c'era una trappola sti stronzi
dovrei stare più attento infatti sono
già scattato però fa niente ah ok
[Musica]
a non sono morto che ha posto pensavo di
essere morto data è un gioco di trappole
questo starà tetto dove mette i piedi
che casino ma mi scusi
posso ficcare la faccia qua dentro
perché ho voglia di fa a
rompere
[Musica]
una ragnatela spero che non ci siano
ragni quando ho mai picture straight
domandare dritto
sento qualcosa di abominevole
grazie avevano detto zio
non mi piace tutto
ma perché non ho continuato gli studi in
informatica sono un cognome e bestie
jovetic densi wildfire sai che c'è e
saccheggia che mi segue uno spider in 3
2 1 ecco il fai io sto correndo poi non
so dove devo arrivare proporro io corro
corro
sono forte sono arrivato fuori tempo
dopo gli andare a casa anche io e sono a
casa figurati no no non iniziamo con i
morti che stanza è questa non lo so però
anche la musica ci si mette attenzione
terrible
beh di sicuro non è roba che mi
interessa io vorrei andare avanti
davanti uscirà questo posto di merda per
favore un pick up ho trovato il piccolo
netto a riti spero che non ci siano
ragno cose però vabbè dai
qualcuno a bloccare qualcuno l'ha
bloccata che infatti qui c'è qualcuno
vivo c'è qualcuno gioco salvato in alta
da meno male ci sono i salvataggi allora
riparto di qua che sono mica rifarsi
tutto all'inizio una ditata nel deretano
mamma ma al ragazzo di munshi si era uno
scheletro quello si risveglia the
thinking in crisi magari già pazza di
tuo nome basta amarezza adesso c'è il
piccole possono minare la resto non
posso
smetti basta basta smettiamola
una bomba la cosa più bella che ho visto
con iniziato sul gioco devo stare
attento ma chi cazzo nel manchester o
per una bomba questa top è
effettivamente una da tutti i torti che
ha messo proprio perché c'è una
motivazione c'è
e non sono io alla ragazzi le bombe non
ho ben capito come dovrei schivarle come
faccio a schivare sta roba è complicata
st parte perché i ragazzi la messa prima
cosa c'entrano in un gioco horror delle
bombe messe così più e anche tappa la
voleva almeno siamo sicuri che quelli
dietro non vengano annoverarono prete
perché mette le bombe la mia era per il
pianista è certo di sicuro non per mia
nonna cioè aveva messe per i ragni fanno
schifo io avrei dato fuoco a tutto però
va bene anche le bombe sono nati o
solution io mi leverei dalle palle se
possibile ci sono altre bombe bombe più
ragnino le mettiamo visto che già è
difficile però giusto tragiche un po di
brio a sta roba
c'è qualcuno che già c'è qui dove a
eccolo a posto zio come va riposino
explore non lo voglio toccare non
toccarlo non equa ci sta un ragno
gigantesco non so perché sosta presso
presentimento cielo tanto le ragnatele
enormi ci sono quindi i ragni ci sono
non è che non ci sono
ancora qui sotto
non benissimo non benissimo per niente
attenzione c'è un ok
ok ma chi cazzo è costruito e ste
miniere con quale criterio potete
arrivare fin qua con le col carrello non
è possibile escludere tra lei mi ricordo
di averla morti una miniera quindi
questo lavoro in una miniera va bene
cazzo è
ma ce la farò mai mi sono accorto troppo
tardi che c'era qui sono morto sono
morto sono morto sono morto morto sono
morto sono forti sono morti su morti
supporto sua morte sono morti sono morti
dei becchini che offre tra chi questa
l'uscita tnt
riesco a dare tutto ateo
è che
la porta era chiusa la porta c'è un
acqua
[Musica]
io ho provato a far explore ma
velocissimo perché non è che c'è tutto
c'è una chiave qua
e che farci sulle scatole da clienti ma
non c'è
peccato che thousand years later aragao
skin nato come un puledro mi sto
sentendo veramente marcel jacobs per ora
preso la chiave l'ho presa esce
o
madonna
ai the
però contento sono sicuro che ci fa
guardare
alla
devo correre a casa e raccontare cosa è
successo questo e come ho vissuto del
giorno nazionale dei funghi la giornata
no ma io io credo
credo
che qualcuno qui si sia fatto di funghi
e non è il protagonista quale come ma
cosa cosa ho scaricato su steam vabbè
questo era il giorno nazionale i funghi
sia piaciuto a me nozze
anche la descrizione sensore si chiede e
noi come sempre signora cecilia anno
prossimo video spese ragazzi
[Musica]